is that it allows for two
classical bits of communication to be packed into a single qubit,
but we have to burn an
e-bit to accomplish this.
Here's a more precise
explanation of the setup.
Once again, we have Alice and Bob, where Alice is the sender
and Bob is the receiver, and this time Alice has two classical bits
that she wants to send to Bob.
Alice is able to send Bob a single qubit and Alice and Bob share
an e-bit that they can use to help them to accomplish their task,
which is for Bob to receive
the two classical bits.
Now, there's a sense in which this task may seem less interesting than the task that
teleportation accomplishes,
particularly if we view
that sending Qubits is significantly more
difficult or more challenging than sending classical bits,
which is a pretty reasonable point of view but it is definitely interesting that it's possible to do this.
One reason why it's interesting
is that it is in fact impossible to accomplish
this task of transmitting two classical bits of information
using a single qubit without
making use of the e-bit.
We know this because of a famous theorem known as Holevo's theorem.
Holevo's theorem is
more general than this, and the precise statement
of Holevo's theorem is a bit technical and it
requires some explanation,
but one implication of it
is that you cannot transmit any number of classical
bits of communication using fewer Qubits of
quantum communication alone.
If you want to reliably transmit two classical bits of
information using Qubits and you don't have an
e-bit to make use of,
you're going to have to send to Qubits, so they might as well store the bits that you wanna transmit.
Another reason why superdense
coding is interesting is because of the close
complementary relationship it has to teleportation, and
we'll come back to this
a little bit later. Here is a quantum circuit description of the superdense coding protocol.
For this one, I won't
list out all the steps, but instead we'll just stick with the circuit diagram description.
As you can see, we again
have Alice and Bob, where Alice is on the top
and Bob is on the bottom.
Here is the e-bit that's
initially shared between Alice and Bob, which has
somehow been established prior to the protocol being run.
Alice has two classical bits, A and B, which you can see up here
and through the protocol that the circuit describes,
these two classical bits
will end up in the hands of Bob.
There's just one qubit
that crosses the line between Alice and Bob, and of course there aren't
any classical bits being sent,
it's the transmission of
the two classical bits that's the point of the protocol.
You'll also notice that it has
exactly the same components that are used in teleportation, we have a controlled NOT
gate, a Hadamard gate,
and a Z and an X-gate
controlled by classical bits.
They're arranged differently however, so let's move on to the
analysis to see how it works.
To analyze how superdense coding works, let's start by writing
down the Bell basis, which is very much at the
heart of the analysis.
What we're going to do is
to first take a look at the effect that Alice's actions
have on the Phi plus state, and what we'll see is
that Alice transforms this
Phi plus state into one
of the four Bell states depending on the bits
that she wants to send.
So, let's write down a table so that we can keep
track of what's going on.
First, if A and B are both zero, then neither the Z-gate nor
the X-gate gets applied, so Alice's actions don't do anything,
which is to say that Phi
plus gets mapped to Phi plus.
We can also express that as an equation like you see right here,
nothing happens to Alice's qubit and nothing happens to Bob's qubit
and doing nothing is represented
by the identity matrix.
Now, what happens if A is equal to zero and B is equal to one?
Well, because B is equal to one, we apply the Z-gate and
we don't apply the X-gate because A is equal to zero
and we see that the overall effect is that Alice performs a Z-gate.
Alice is on the right
because she's on the top, although it wouldn't
actually make any difference in this particular
case, the effect is that
the Phi plus date gets
snapped to Phi minus, which you can eyeball
from these expressions if you remember how a Z-gate works works.
So, we can add this one to our table, there are two more cases to go through, if A is equal to one
and B is equal to zero,
then Alice performs an
X-gate which transforms five Phi into Chi plus, and if A is equal to one
and B is equal to one,
then Alice performs Z, then
X and we get Chi minus.
So, our table tells us what happens in the four possible cases and that is that Alice effectively chooses which one